foreign
[Music]
we have now seen eight dragons in House
of the Dragon almost all the targaryens
have their own Dragons by now so the
question is which dragons are on which
side what are the dragons on Queen
Alison's side that is the greens and
which ones are on renero's side that is
the blacks we will now show you the
present lineup and then the final one as
explained in the books so let's get to
it
as of season 1 episode 7 the Targaryen
black fashion with rhaenyra at the helm
consists of the following Dragon Riders
princess rhaenyra himself Prince Damon
Targaryen princess rhaenys lady Baylor
Targaryen Prince luceris and Prince
jakaris while the green faction with
Queen Alison controlling the strings
have three dragon Riders as of now they
are Prince aegon II prince aemon and
princess Helena so let's dive into the
dragons that they have on each side
so as of now the dragons we have on the
side of the blacks are Cyrax caraxis sea
smoke melees Vermax and Moon Dancer out
of these six dragons one is now
riderless and one is too small to ride
and another one is just hinted at and
not yet shown well we have seen Cyrax
right from the beginning of the show she
was smaller back then and by the time of
the most recent episode she has grown
into a bigger medium-sized bees garaxis
the blood worm of Prince Daemon is
surprisingly the same of a similar size
since the beginning maybe due to a
slower aging and growth process in his
body after a certain time
melees we have seen once or twice is
bigger than all the rest except for
vegar she is termed as the Red Queen and
has a header Dawn with a crown of horns
vormax is the small dragon that is
bonded to Young Prince Jaker's valerion
and was green in color now we come to
the riderless dragon which is sea smoke
who now since the departure of Lena
Valerian has known to ride him but rest
assured he will be claimed Again by
another
the only one left is Moon Dancer which
is Baylor's dragon and hasn't been shown
yet but since they have stated that the
young Targaryen already has a dragon it
means that Moon Dancer is already on the
side of the blacks
now let's go to the dragons that we have
on the side of the greens they are vegar
Sunfire and dream fire Vega the biggest
was first seen in the series as being
the dragon man of Lady Elena valerion
and after her death on the night of a
funeral the Young Prince Ayman Targaryen
approached the dragon and claimed it as
his own afterwards leading to a scuffle
with the other kids and him losing an
eye the next dragon is Sunfire who is
bonded to Young aegon II Sunfire is a
golden dragon that looks very similar to
Cyrax in a way with the Sleek body
design the coloration the golden
coloration and haunts and the last one
is dream fire that is seen slightly in
the past couple of episodes as she has a
pale blue dragon that is written by
Princess Helena Targaryen and looks very
similar to Sea smoke in design
so those are the dragons of the two
factions as of now but later on there
will be more dragons and dragon Riders
as well as a few ones changing size
during the war so let's take a look at
them all at the end of the dance of the
Dragons the black faction would have had
control over 13 dragons with a couple of
them changing sides due to treachery of
the Dragon Riders whereas the greens
will have a total of eight dragons on
their side at the End by the end meaning
with a couple of them defected from the
blacks so this is the roster of the
black faction the dragons and the
respective Dragon Riders let's take a
look
firstly we will have Cyrax with Princess
renera Targaryen then caraxis with demon
Targaryen Vermax with jakaris valerion
seismo with Adam valerion melees with
Princess rhaenys Targaryen Moon Dancer
with Lady Baylor
Eric's with luceris tyraxis with Joffrey
morning with Reina Targaryen storm cloud
with Prince aegon the younger sheep
stealer with Nettles Verma Thor with
Hugh hammer and Silver Wing with oath
the white although the last two writers
would be the ones defecting to the
greens hence reducing the number of
dragons on rhenera's side
so coming to the other side by the end
of the dance of the Dragons the green
faction would have had control over
these dragons along with the Riders of
course Vega with Prince Eamon Targaryen
Sunfire with Prince slash King aegon II
dream fire with his sister wife princess
Helena Targaryen and the she Dragon the
serial known as the blue Queen with
Prince Deron Targaryen we will also have
morgul with Princess jehera Targaryen
shrikas with Prince jahiris Targaryen
and later the two dragons of vermouth
and Silverwing along with their Riders
Hugh hammer and elf the white who would
abandon the blacks and join the greens
and that is the video on the dragons of
the black and green factions of House of
the dragon as well as the bigger play
the dance of the Dragons so I hope you
have enjoyed watching this video do hit
the like button for support and
subscribe but most of all smash that
Bell icon for regular updates on new
videos here on this channel till the
next one take care fam